which is
one of the things that frustrates me
about this world
is uh they don't celebrate
the success of others like
there's so many people that want elon to
fail
it's so fascinating to me like what
is wrong with you like uh so
elon musk talks about like people short
like they talk about financial
but i think it's much bigger than the
financials i've seen like the human
factors community
they want they want other people to fail
why why why like even people the
harshest thing is like
you know even people that like seem to
really hate donald trump
they want him to fail yeah i know or
like the other president or they want
barack obama to fail it's like
yeah we're almost involved it's weird
but
i i want that i would love to inspire
that part of the world to change because
well damn it if the human species is
going to survive we should celebrate
success
like it seems like the efficient thing
to do in this objective function that
like we're all striving for
is to celebrate the ones that put like
figure out how to like do better at that
objective function
as opposed to like dragging them down
back into them
into the mud i think there is this is
the speech i always give about the
commenters on hacker news
um so first off something to remember
about the internet in general
is commenters are not representative of
the population
yeah i don't comment on anything i don't
you know
commentaries are are representative of a
certain sliver of the population
and on hacker news a common thing i'll
say is when you'll see something that's
like
you know promises to be wild out there
and in
innovative there is some amount of you
know
checking them back to earth but there's
also some amount of if this thing
succeeds
well i'm 36 and i've worked at
large tech companies my whole life
they can't succeed because if they
succeed that would mean that
i could have done something different
with my life but we know that i couldn't
have we know that i couldn't have and
and that's why they're going to fail
and they have to root for them to fail
to kind of maintain their world image
so tune it out and they comment well
it's hard
i uh so one of the things one of the
things i'm considering
startup wise is to change that
because i think the i think it's also
a technology problem it's a platform
problem
it's like because the thing you said
most people don't comment
i think most people want to comment
they just don't because it's all the
for commenting exactly i don't
want to be grouped in with that or not
you don't want to be in a at a party
where everyone is an
and so they but that's a platform
problem that's
i can't believe what reddit's become i
can't believe the group think in reddit
comments
there's a red is an interesting one
because they're subreddits
and so you can still see especially
small subreddits
that like that are little like havens of
like
joy and positivity and like deep
even disagreement but like nuanced
discussion but
it's only like small little pockets but
that's
uh that's emergent the platform is not
helping that or
hurting that so i guess naturally
something about the internet uh if you
don't put in a lot of effort to
encourage
nuance and positive good vibes it's
naturally going to decline into chaos
i would love to see someone do this well
yeah um i think it's
yeah very doable this is uh i think
actually so
i i feel like twitter could be
overthrown joshua bach talked about how
like uh
if you have like and retweet like
that's only positive wiring right
the only way to do anything like
negative there
is um with a comment and
that's like that asymmetry is what gives
you know twitter its particular
toxicness
whereas i find youtube comments to be
much better because youtube comments
have a
have a of a top and a down and they
don't show the downloads
without getting into depth of this
particular discussion the point is
to explore possibilities and get a lot
of data on it because
uh i mean i could disagree with what you
just said it's it's um
the point is it's unclear it's a it
hasn't been explored in a really rich
way
uh like the these questions of how to
create
platforms that encourage positivity yeah
i think it's a it's a technology problem
and i think we'll look back at twitter
as it is now maybe it'll happen within
twitter but most likely
somebody overthrows them is
we'll look back at twitter and and say
we can't believe we put up with this
level of toxicity you need a different
business model too any any social
network that fundamentally has
advertising as a business model
this was in the social dilemma which i
didn't watch but i liked it it's like
you know there's always the you know
you're the product you're not the uh
but they had a nuanced take on it that i
really liked and it said the product
being sold
is influence over you
the product being sold is literally your
you know
influence on you like
that can't be if that's your idea okay
well
you know guess what it can't not be
toxic yeah
maybe there's ways to spin it like with
with uh giving a lot more control to the
user and transparency to see what is
happening to them as opposed to
in the shadows as possible but that
can't be the primary source of
but the users aren't no one's going to
use that it depends it depends it
depends
i think i think that the you're you're
not going to
you can't depend on self-awareness of
the users
it's a it's another it's a longer
discussion because uh you can't depend
on it but
you can reward self-awareness
like if for the ones who are willing to
put in the work of self-awareness
you can reward them and incentivize and
perhaps
be pleasantly surprised how many people
are are willing to be self-aware on the
internet
like we are in real life like i'm
putting a lot of effort with you right
now
being self-aware about if i say
something stupid or mean
sure i'll like look at your like body
language like i'm putting in that effort
it's costly for an introvert it's very
costly
but on the internet it
like most people are like i don't care
if this hurts somebody i don't care if
this uh
is not interesting or if this is yeah
the mean or whatever
i think so much of the engagement today
on the internet is so disingenuous too
yeah you're not doing this out of a
genuine this is what you think you're
doing this just straight up to
manipulate
others whether you're in you just became
an ad
you